as you're waking up this morning
temperatures are soaring in the
Northeast again today after a day of
historic and deadly hot weather heat
advisories are in effect from New York
to Massachusetts temperatures could feel
higher than 90 again today thousands of
people in Boston lost power yesterday as
the city hit a record-breaking high of
98 degrees and on New York's Long Island
an 11-year old girl was pulled
unconscious from a parked car and later
died at a hospital and in Philadelphia
High School teacher was reportedly
hospitalized and numerous students got
heat related illnesses meteorologist
Danielle knives of our Boston station
WBZ has the forecast Danielle good
morning Nora good morning to you so the
good news is the heat won't be as
extreme as it was the past couple of
days yes we still have heat advisories
in effect but for a smaller area overall
heat index topping out in the mid 90s
today in the hottest areas not the
record heat but nonetheless up and down
the eastern seaboard it's still gonna be
stifling in spots the forecast heat
index today topping out 90 to 100
degrees all the way from Boston
stretching back down to the Carolinas
there is some relief on the way though
cooler drier air less humid air on the
way particularly for the Northeast
Buffalo to New York City to Boston highs
in the 70s tomorrow gonna feel actually
a little bit on the cool side but a
welcome change unfortunately it looks
like for the second half of the holiday
weekend there's no real change in the
jet stream a big Ridge in the eastern
two-thirds of the country going to mean
heat and humidity build back in
particularly by Sunday and Labor Day
highs will top out over 90 it looks like
this heat is gonna stay in place through
the middle part of next week as we kick
off the month of September 90 Plus could
be another heat wave with record
temperatures for next week so we'll keep
an eye on that Adrianna back to you
Danielle thanks